you're a great musician both played in  the musical comedy world we thought  maybe you'd have a little something for  us I'm gonna do Neil Young but I need a  topic for a song anything we have not  prepared this anything or anyone the  crowd one of you who someone come on  tinder eaglebones  Lugo follows bombing was that a bit you  guys yeah we were threatened Richard  that's what rich is holding yeah I was a  little bummed you don't have to do that  you do it you can do flu the bone that's  a horn that Ritchie's pretending to play  over okay  [Music]  you've got that part out when Richie was  a little boy  his mom goddamn bike  Oh  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  you